talk about all of that should we uh with
the man who is very much in the know
james cleveland the education secretary
is with us in the studio hi good morning
good morning how are you uh yeah not too
bad no congratulations
yeah thank you it's a fantastic job
education so it goes without saying
incredibly important so it's a fantastic
job yeah um just to clarify before we go
any further did he actually resign
yesterday because i didn't hear him say
resign or resignation at any stage oh i
think we can take that as read i mean i
i didn't do a word analysis of the
speech but he is standing down and he
made it clear at cabinet that um
that it was a pleasure to serve the
country but now we need to get a new
leader uh and he expects us in the
intervening period of time to focus on
delivering for the british people that's
absolutely right why does he think he
had to resign
well ultimately to be prime minister you
have to
have the ability to form a government
and when government colleagues in such
numbers are saying that they
didn't want to serve under him then that
i fear became inevitability uh and it's
right that he has stood down it's right
that he has um put a team in place
to continue governing whilst the
selection procedure goes for his
successor
and we should do that i think pretty
quickly pretty promptly and then we can
get very much focused on what we should
always be focused on which is as i say
delivering for the people of this
country listening to his speech he
didn't sound as though he'd done
he felt that he'd done anything wrong
well i
i think clearly he recognized that
he wasn't able to form a government that
was that was that was clear um
he he's he you know he is standing down
i think
i'm sure and you're gonna do analysis
later on i'm sure there'll be plenty of
people that do a word for word analysis
you can do a body language analysis we
raked over i have no doubt but the fact
is now that he is handing on to a
successor who will be chosen i think
pretty promptly and then we will all of
us here in uh in the government
focus on as i say delivering for the
british people at an incredibly
turbulent time both domestically and
internationally does he acknowledge he
did anything wrong you know him well
you've been well he's apologizing yeah
he has a point
he has he has apologized he's apologized
uh as i say i'm not gonna do a word
analysis of the speech but he has
apologized for the situation and he is
standing here standing down and i think
now the thing that uh that i will be
doing my colleagues will be doing i
think everyone else will be doing now is
focusing on the future focusing on who's
coming next what their agenda will be
and how we continue
servicing the people that put us into
parliament and put us into government he
feels that changing prime minister is an
eccentric decision do you think the same
well
as i say i'm focused on what happens
next
um look you will want to you want to do
analysis of what has just happened i'm
just asking about that yeah it's
eccentric and i'm saying i'm saying i'm
focusing and the government is focusing
on the future which is the right thing
to do and the future is about making
sure we have a new prime minister and
prime minister and governmental team in
place promptly and in the meantime
continue to serve the british people
what's his role now
his role now he remains prime minister
until a new prime minister is uh is
found that's how our system works
i think that everyone recognizes the
incentive of doing that properly and
professionally but quickly
so that we can get some certainty and so
the new prime minister whoever that may
be can build their team and make sure
they're uh continuing to to focus on
what really matters and that's the
people of this country he did say didn't
want to influence major policy why did
he replace five cabinet positions
minutes before he resigned then
well he has to form a government we have
to have a functioning government
he has put people in place i looked
around the cabinet table there's a
wealth of experience uh around the
cabinet table to make sure that we
continue
delivering government because the world
does not stop the issues that we deal
with don't stop so he has a duty to
ensure that government it's not his
cabinet anymore is it well it is until
the new prime minister is uh
no but the point is that there are
day-to-day decisions that have to be
made in all kinds of departments across
government um what he has said is he is
not going to make decisions that would
uh limit the options for his successor
that would be wrong i think that is the
right and honorable thing to do so he's
a caretaker prime minister to all
intents and purposes does that make you
a caretaker education section well you
are in the job that you are in doing the
job that you are doing until you are
replaced that is how it always works
in politics none of us know exactly how
long we're going to be in our roles um
ultimately i'm not going to focus on i'm
not going to focus on how long or
whatever there are decisions that need
to be uh taken uh in education we're
moving into the exam results season
we're moving into school places season
we're moving into university admissions
seasons there are decisions that need to
be made i've already spoken with a
number of union leaders and a number of
bodies in the education sector i did
that on my first day at work i and my
colleagues i'm sure will be exactly the
same we'll be working hard to deliver
good professional functioning government
for as long as we're in place if that's
a short time or a long time none of us
know okay will you be pushing for the
nine percent for teachers pay increase
that your predecessor who is predecessor
before last who is now the chancellor uh
was pushing for when he was education
section will you still be pushing for we
absolutely uh look and uh as i've been
doing this job now for uh less than 24
hours i'm i'm going to be looking of
course at all these things including my
teachers watching of course and look um
are you going to be i i am going to i am
going to be uh analyzing exactly all the
decisions that that that i need to to
take in terms of an open door in terms
of internal challenges he's already said
yes in terms of teachers pay i recognize
how very important that is particularly
in the time
of inflation uh and of course i will
looking very seriously at that and we'll
be making is that yesterday
or not i tell you something i uh i don't
think it would be very professional of
me to start making uh decisions on the
who for making announcements here in the
studio how why is that on the hoof uh
when they because i was appointed yes
well that's no excuse is it yeah i'm
guessing you think that you're very good
at the job i mean you've been in in
government a long time you know where
this works you know how to be very good
at a job okay i know because i and i
know this is what you do
is you are thoughtful you are analytical
you make decisions promptly but you
don't rush them that's exactly how i am
well prepared when i come in for
interviews oh absolutely
and i'm well prepared to not answer that
question okay even though you know that
the chancellor would say yes if you said
nine percent
i said i mean you can keep asking the
same question i'm going to give you the
same answer and i'm very sorry at home
if you're watching and getting ready for
school i did ask him he did um talk to
me about this party that i'm hearing
about this wedding party at uh checkers
which is the grace and favor home of the
prime minister not the caretaker prime
minister there is no such thing as okay
there's no such thing as a caretaker
prime he's not the prime minister
in our system there is a prime minister
what's he resigned from then he is
resigned he has resigned uh he's
resigning from
his role as prime minister and leader of
the party once or so he's not yet
represented once a successor has been
approved so he hasn't yet resigned
is that what you're saying what i'm
saying is he's made an announcement you
can agree
resign in his speech well if you don't
think he's going we'll take a big bet on
whether he's still prime minister so
he's prime minister so he's still
allowed to use his grace and favor home
so is it right that he has his wedding
party there well look as i say um i
don't know the details uh about that
i've seen some media speculation
unsurprisingly that was not part of the
discussion that i have not got an invite
with him it's not part of the discussion
that i've had with have you had an
invite no no no so
so so the point is you're not flipping
invites so if you get one where you go
so the so the point is look the point is
he is um he is very very clear that we
are here to serve the british people he
is also very clear that we do that until
the new prime minister is in place and
that's what he is doing personally and
we will continue to work as a say
focusing on the things we should be
focusing on which is the delivery of
good government for this country the
optics though of having a wedding party
during a cost of living crisis when we
are potentially about to go into
recession you have to accept that would
not be very good well people have
weddings and wedding parties all the
time people have
uh you know it is celebrating
celebrating um getting married to
someone you love i think is the most
natural and wonderful thing in the world
and i don't begrudge that of anybody and
i know a lot of people i i had
constituents a lot of people had their
wedding celebrations delayed because of
covid and they're looking to celebrate
their love now there is nothing wrong
with that and i'm not going to criticize
it is uh
is it right that the taxpayer my viewers
this morning would pick up any amount of
that bill for that wedding party well i
i my understanding and i'm yeah i don't
pretend to be an expert on this i've
i've um i don't have the details about
how checkers work my understanding is
that private functions are not paid out
to the public person yeah but there'd be
extra security when there was hundreds
of people there
uh i don't necessarily know that that is
the case i think the security
arrangements of
of um government buildings are what they
are they are they are a standing cost
where they're pretty confident that
there won't be any cost to the tax well
so as i say my understanding is that
private expenditure is not funded out
the public person okay so there won't be
any cost to the tax that's my
understanding okay and if you got an
invite would you go of course i would go
he's yeah long-standing friend and
colleague i know him really well i know
carrie really well
but as i say i'm not so presumptuous and
i don't you know i don't want to i don't
want to get uh i don't get told off
by uh by anyone them or mrs c for
presumptively
inserting myself in someone else's
celebration well i think she should
probably buy a hat just in case is what
i'm suggesting uh will you stand for
leader
uh no i won't be um
so my
uh
as you know i put myself forward last
time i don't regret that i really
enjoyed it um as you know
my my wife has been going through cancer
treatment and whilst that is progressing
well it hasn't concluded it's not the
right time for me
um and i feel comfortable that actually
we have a range of
uh candidates within the party that
would make excellent prime ministers
and before you ask the next obvious
question i haven't decided who i'm gonna
support yet i wasn't good what i was
going to ask you i was going to ask you
how you miss is doing oh that's
yeah she's it's it's it's going well the
the medical team
guys and the teammates and thomases that
she's working with have been
absolutely amazing things are
progressing well she's uh she's um she's
not quite back
to her
uh pre-treatment self but the treatment
seems to have been going very very well
but the boys are okay yeah it's always
tough but it is always tough and seeing
seeing someone you love go through that
is not easy and i know this is something
that touches
so many families so many women
across the across the country um but as
i say the the treatment she's had um the
the the the team as i say both guys
cancer and thomas have been absolutely
unbelievable i cannot praise them highly
enough but absolutely fantastic and then
i was going to ask you who you're going
i have not decided yet we'll we'll see
who the criteria we'll see look the
criteria is really simple someone that
would someone that would be
a good
uh
governor of the of um uh the the
government someone who will uh
be a good campaigner someone who will
form a good government uh look brexit's
done
so brexit that's right
we're almost outside that's for another
conversation uh what about one of those
um that has stabbed your boss in the
back would you still vote for them well
as i say i
i think that we have a
um i think we've got a range of
candidates i do think actually
that
demonstrating loyalty to others is
important if you want people to
demonstrate loyalty to you
um
and i think that that will be one of the
criteria that is taken very very
seriously
by not just myself but by a range of
people but as i say we have a number of
people who are who would make excellent
excellent prime ministers i think we're
spoilt for choice
final thought before i let you go um we
heard from sir john major saying that
potentially in order to expedite what's
going on you could uh get rid of the
grassroots vote so
conservative members watching us this
morning would not get a vote in who the
next prime minister would be
so like john major has an opinion i
disagree with that i think what we saw
with
uh theresa may that testing
a future prime minister's ability to
campaign and campaign across the country
is really important theresa may had many
many many fantastic attributes but what
we saw in the 2017 general election she
was not a natural campaigner and that
was not good for government
so i think testing the ability of a
candidate to reach out beyond the
westminster bubble is incredibly
important so i think it's an important
part of the process thank you for
joining us in regards to your good lady
hope that she continues to be well thank
you